what's your your writing process like
because some people nowadays you know
they're just getting the boot and
they'll just kind of punch in linebacker
that's what i'm doing that's what you're
doing all right so there's no writing
down
let's go in and figure it out go in and
figure it out i'm a punch rapper is it
harder to learn your verses that way
yeah i mean
sometimes i'm gonna i'm putting like
that sometimes it is like
with me for some reason like
once i hear probably once or two times i
mean catch most of the verse right right
right cause i feel like when you write
it you probably memorize it a little bit
more oh you for you you definitely do
because i you like when i first started
rapping like even back when i was
wrapping my brother busy like when i
used to do that i used to write
it got to when i met rio newton when i
stopped writing
it's more efficient to not write if
you're in the studio let me tell you why
i get more done right tell me why i'm
going to tell you why i had to stop
right now
we at e house
you know i'm saying that he had the
studio that's when we started making the
music
and
i was still right at this point the
[ __ ] like [ __ ] pull up a beat
and i get to write
and these [ __ ] had all son done and
they're waiting on you
they had a whole song done before i'm
doing my verse um
so it'd be like
it was it was awesome [ __ ] to where he
you got to get with her to get lost
i'm like [ __ ] that y'all after they keep
leaving me i don't see [ __ ] i was just
[ __ ] yeah it's like faster of a
process to do with the punching way
because like you'll have somebody who's
like sitting in the corner with their
pad or their iphone
you know writing and then by the time
that's done the verse and the hook from
someone else listen man verses from
verses from us like we really be wild
with people bro like
with how fast you you lay [ __ ] you can
ask my managers what's the most amount
of songs you've recorded in a night
[ __ ]
probably like two three tapes
jesus we listen it take me six minutes
six seven minutes to do a verse 16
that's crazy
like for real and i'm saying in my life
like yeah who are you just blessed like
that for some reason and i know you're
probably thinking like yeah you're
probably just saying no like sometimes
you're [ __ ] saying some dope [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like fast like
well that's gotta be great for the like
i'm on the road hit me dm me for the
feature go book a studio in a random
city and then you got
every six minutes you're making x amount
of money hey listen it'd be funny though
because you know like
when people be paying for features and
[ __ ] they probably get offended that you
did it so easily they're like yo i just
paid you for that i don't even know like
something some [ __ ] be cool but some
of them be like
you know when you when you when you pass
somebody for a few you down there want
to be in the studio catching five kick
you think we finna be in this [ __ ]
chilling right you think
you know unless we doing the video or
something yeah like what are we doing
you want me to hang out for your vloggy
i need another [ __ ]
no but it'd be
[Music]
quicker than me
yeah he's serious that's crazy he's
getting that [ __ ] and you just go i
feel like crazy
and he give it